is what kind of shape is this okay so
let's quickly go through I've seen the
right out of right of all your pages so
far but just in case you're struggling a
little bit with it let's give it a go
so this is the ratio is equal to 1/2
yeah and I think before because we're
using all of the same features okay
nothing right inside it gonna come up we
can quite a lot at least for a little
while so I think we're not having let's
see square root of x squared plus y
squared plus 1 plus 1 is equal to this
right yep good okay now you guys know
from doing the locus before that one of
the class he would get his errors is to
square everything and to forget any
constants that are there okay so don't
do it you may even like to put that harm
over the other side because then you'll
be dealing with whole numbers okay
actually I will get two fractions later
on but it's it's sort of easier to work
with so we have 4x squared plus y
squared plus 2y plus 1 y squared plus 8y
plus 16 by the way I did mention before
so most of you not the three of you that
are nearly all my class is the human
rule right treat me like a newbie I
treat you like one too one of those
things is that to fur is human so I will
make mistakes I can guarantee it
this isn't one of them but I just
pre-empting myself okay so catch him out
I used to I had a I don't lecture
actually who he had attacked he had an
air attack so anyone who you could find
an error in pay me 20 cents that's a
while ago I should probably bump that up
like inflation or that but off I try to
work out what it'll be so let's see what
are we gonna get 4x squared plus 4y
squared plus my
Plus ball so what are we gonna get now
eight Y's cancel I'm gonna bring the
clothes since all ever on the right-hand
side if you haven't done that already
that's okay but for reasons that will
become clear in a second it's gonna be
simpler for us so I'm gonna get four
from 16 is 12 1 y squared over here is
three of you here so what do you
probably up something and that's fine
okay excuse me
however if you have just stop there I'd
like to drag one extra line which is to
divide a future by 12 what okay now so
have you already drawn this that's
actually how many of you've drawn it
what is this thing it's my question what
kind of shape is it no this is short
answer and there's a there's an answer
which takes a little more thinking okay
so let me consider what would happen for
instance if I change that to more for
okay what kind of shape is this you know
it's a circle because if you wouldn't
multiply through about how do we read
are looking fractions you have X square
plus y square equals cool okay so it's
almost the unit circle it's twice the
radius the area and so on so that's a
circle but the fact that this is not a
form but it's a three okay means that
when you're adjusting one and the other
by different quantities okay you're kind
of squeezing and squashing but not in
the same proportions okay so what are
the intercepts for this thing and that's
why you'll see it's it's useful to have
the one over here with other fractions
over here when you look at the
intercepts okay
for instance let's work out the X
intercepts how do we do that why cause
you're so that's gonna leave you two x
squared on three equals one okay so x
squared equals three so your plus or
minus about one point seven yeah which
is important we're gonna graph this
intercept do the same things you get
your wire intercepts and you can put me
at ease
right when I Square before is one okay
so let's let's skip a step because I
thought you can handle that
so plus/minus 21.72 now you're getting a
sense for the scale so what kind of
thing is this it's like a circle but
it's a squash house watch is it that's
how wide it is
and it's just a smidge taller than it is
wide
I was doing so well okay so there you go
it's an ellipse now I'm pretty much
going to stop there but I'm gonna put
some labels on to this okay because we
need to be able to describe this in some
way okay firstly this is what we ended
when we start but yeah what was the
beginning of this thing we started with
a focus and a directrix that's it now
hold on have a look at this thing where
are the focus and the directrix I'd
probably do myself just enough space
down here the directions at minus four
so I'm down here okay where's the focus
so it's kind of words halfway between
the origin and that lowest point isn't
it yes okay so there's the focus
there's the directrix but you might
notice because of the symmetry of this
shape this shape has a symmetry that the
parabola so just whacked off doesn't
have okay it's got this kind of
reflectional surgery so this is not the
only focus this is not the only
directrix where else could I put them I
could reflect across the x-axis couldn't
so I couldn't yes there it would be one
zero one okay and I have a side of focus
there yeah and the directrix at y equals
positive 4 okay so when we're looking at
questions to do with ellipses okay we're
no longer talking about a focus in a
directrix we're talking about
firk hi and director sees okay because
it's not like one is more the focus than
the other or one direction is more
important area in exactly equal okay so
in the questions that we asked to find
out both